selfless best of the best Mentor coach
those were some of the words describing
49 year old officer turongtai more than
2 000 people in fact were at the funeral
at the church in Henderson not just
family and friends and fellow officers
but also First Responders from across
the country Madison Kimbrough has more
I can tell you that I was never a person
for fame or a fortune
to him
it was service Pride honor integrity
uh that was much more meaning for her
when you hear words from family friends
and fellow police about officer trong
Tai they all have the same description
officer Greg Hilton shared memories of
Tai on and off the clock Christmas day
is at my house for dinner
the kids had gotten a small air hockey
table
and they'd been trying to get Ty to play
air hockey with them the entire time we
were there he agreed and he played with
them for over an hour
this is the exact opposite of me when I
play air hockey with my children this
experience didn't mean much to me until
recently
a little playing air hockey with one of
my children
he said Dad
look what Ty taught me
and then he proceeded to demonstrate how
to hold the paddle how to take certain
shots officer Carlos Carreon who worked
closely with him looked to him as a
mentor it was someone I could always use
to lean on
and I knew
he would always be there long after he
retired
I never expected her picture at a time
that I would not be able to go to him
ask him questions
talk to him
and his family saying that Metro's care
in all of this is what has helped them
get through and I will take comfort in
knowing that he died doing what he truly
loved and what he was called to do
he died as he lived protecting others
although you are no longer here you will
forever be in our hearts
you will never be forgotten I know that
you will be watching over us as we press
forward
we can also tell you that there was a
private burial ceremony taking place
today with just close friends colleagues
and his family in attendance